a hi everyone welcome to the price
rejecter in or x my name is Michael
vatos i'm the founder and trader at
overflows calm first brief disclaimer
this presentation is for educational
informational purposes only it should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell futures contractor make any
other type of investment decision
Futures Trading contain substantial risk
is not for every investor an investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment risk capital is
money that can be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle only risk capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
so what I'm going to talk about today is
the price rejecter and what is the price
rejecter it's an order flow tool
designed to work on a normal bar chart
now if you're unfamiliar with me you go
to my website WWF laws calm and you'll
learn more about me and I've been
trading for over 20 years on an
institutional level after leaving
JPMorgan or has been eight years of my
life I started trading on my own and the
order flow software out there was okay
but you know it didn't really analyze
the order flow the way I like to analyze
or derful so I came up with my own
software I got a programmer to you know
I gave up my requirements and came up
with a brilliant solution for me and you
go to my website learn more about it at
order flows calm now the price rejecter
is an indicator based on order flow
analysis people have come to me traders
have come to me asking for a tool that
they could just put on their normal
chart you know they don't want to look
at a volume footprint chart you just
want to stick with their normal bar
chart okay so we worked on something and
came up with the price rejecter it runs
on the ninja trader trading platform to
learn more about that go to ww energy
trader calm you can download their
software for free they have a paid
version which is good if you want to use
the software to out your orders through
the market but you don't need the paid
version the free
version you can use you know trade in
simulation mode or you know just follow
the market still you feel comfortable
opening up an account and getting a paid
version of the software the price
rejecter takes into account the volume
traded on the bid and offer recent price
action marketing balances and is the
market trending or trading in a range
why is that last part important well if
you're going to take a trade you want to
take a trade you know when a mark a move
has ended and a new move is about the
start you want to just take a trade in
the middle of a market going nowhere or
a market that's going sideways now
you're going to have a lower probability
of success you want to give your chance
give yourself a chance to have a more
profitable trade so you want to get that
the edge of a move the end of a move or
you know the beginning of a new move now
the price rejecter is based on order
flow it's not based on lagging
indicators such as moving averages Mac
dersi anything like that if it's not is
based on market generated information
like said you know the volume traded on
a bit offer price action market
imbalances and it determines whether
you've been trending or stuck in a range
okay so that said you know this is I'm
going to show some charts from this
morning okay this is it's Tuesday jun
21st it's five just after five thirty
Chicago time okay so this is a
one-minute euro USD chart the data comes
from kinetic and it's the fxcm data feed
the date is June twenty-first 2016 this
is Chicago time here so in the morning
220 just after well 225 you got a cell
signal here and we traded down from you
know one 1348 down to you know 30 36 37
level then you get a buy signal we trade
up to you know back up to the 45 46
level get a cell signal down to another
by signal for where you were earlier 36
37 and you get a by Sigma
it started to go up and then it failed
you know but you have to have stops in
because when you're trying to find a
recent low or you wanna swing high or
swing below you know sometimes it's
going the mark is gonna take a while to
find it and you know so you got one you
know whom you got this high boom you got
this little boom you got this high boom
you look like you're going to get this
low but you know the market wasn't
convinced that this was going to be your
low and you know we traded lower so so
this train didn't work out so yeah you
know one winner two winners three
winners loser okay so what happens we
just trade lower lower lower boom you
get another by starts going you know it
starts to work out but that just goes
sideways on you for how many minutes
that's let's comment you know one bar
two bars three bars for bars five bars
six bars again it's you know five bars
where you're just going nowhere you know
move that happened it's up to you
whether or not you want to stay in a
trade five bars that's going nowhere and
it came down you know capitulo 33 which
is sort of the low for the entry signal
I mean really the entry would be in the
next bar at around this 35 level so you
know God then be none where you have
your stop you're going to use you know
one take two to three tix for tix five
tix it's up to you again in this market
so just one sideways when work is going
sideways it's not usually the best idea
to stay inside a trade you want to get
out at either a small profit or small
loss or you know give it keep it a
little bit more breathing movement for
going sideways you think the market is
consolidating before you make a move in
one direction or the other you're not
going to have a tight stop you might
want to loosen it out a little bit so
you know we just sort of hanging around
again you just hanging around hanging
around yeah eventually we started going
higher this is at five o'clock you know
again you know i said i'm recording this
at five-thirty you just after five
thirty Chicago time so this is five
o'clock get a by a quick pop up here and
you know this is where we are right now
you got this by here which again is just
kind of going going sideways on you a
little bit lower your entry would be
somewhere on this 40 area right now
we're trading 39 it's already how many
bars in there one two three four five
again you guys decide you want to
with that or not you know what you want
is a quick move up you know get your tix
get your pips and move on to the next
trade okay just real quick this is a
euro USD five minute chart Bruno signals
this morning you know I'm showing it
just so you know there was no signal so
you don't say I didn't show you because
there was a bunch of signals that failed
you know I'm throwing it up there just
so you can see there was no no lies no
cells on this euro USD five miniature
okay here's a euro japanese yen chart
it's a five-minute chart before clock
you got a cell signal and you know we
traded down from this area in here on
the the 40 38 39 level it's 5 minute
chart now I'll trade it down good 15 tix
almost 20 ticks that we could get down
to 20 plus about 25 move came back up
you got another cell signal but this one
didn't work out this one was stopped
y'all so you had a nice one nice trade
one loser there okay so thanks for
watching this video to learn more about
the trading software used in this
presentation and how you can profit from
order flow trading visit my website WWF
lows calm or www ice rejecter calm you
know I am humble sites you can you can
see I got an hour long video that really
explains the price rejecter in depth on
the price rejecter site so you know
check it out and give it a try you know
I think it's as traitor yet to have
different tools in your toolbox and if
you're trading with just one methodology
one set up you know they're going to hit
bad stretches you need different setups
that are going to be crying at different
times and you know trading is a bit like
building a house you know you're going
to use a hammer but then you need a
screwdriver you need a wrench any pliers
you need different tools in your toolbox
now if you're just approaching the
market with one thing then you know
what's not working it gets bounced a
broken but you know the tool get broken
but you know one when your way of
trading isn't working
then it's time to look at it another way
and you know the nice thing about the
price rejecters said it could run on a
normal bar chart you don't need an order
flows chart although I do think you know
to get to get the most out of it you
should be you know analyzing it in
context of the market rather than just
taking trades without any kind you know
any context of what the volume is doing
or where the market is going so you'll
give it you know watch the video you
know give it a try and you know I think
you'll be pleasantly surprised so thanks
for watching and see you on the inside